sometimes I think in a uh non sports
environment nonathletic
environment the people who come in might
not react as well to that as in a sports
environment because necessity makes it
clear and you do it sometimes it's more
challenging than that when you deal with
a weakness I'll give you an example we
had a case where we rate all the
different
people and for a lot of statistics and
so on and these are your baseball cards
these are baseball cards right and then
we have a list and somebody's last on
the
list okay some people can go through
that and some people can't go through
that but it's it's okay here are your
points and that's what it is and what do
you do to get better you always want to
help people so it takes a certain kind
of person in our environment to say okay
that's where I am on the list and what
do I do about it and it's not so easy
sometimes I suspect it's more
straightforward in your game do you
think I well I do I think the good thing
is to be on the list to be part of the
New England Patriots I've been last on
the list before um and you either find
ways to create more value for yourself
on the team and in the organization or
they replace you uh so I think all of us
most all of us have been last on the
list at some point in time um but yeah
again to me the important thing is you
know making a commitment to to get
better and so you know is it hard to
admit your weaknesses yes but again if
you don't address them your opponents
will that's
right